دمى باربي الواقعية ، صممت ماتيل باربي
فريدة من نوعها
كأفضل تكريم لها لستة أبطال حقيقيين
من الوباء طبيبان
وطبيب نفسي وممرض في الخطوط الأمامية
وأستاذ قاد تطوير
لقاح وباحث في الطب الحيوي
واحد من هؤلاء  المكرمون هم الدكتورة أودري سو
كروز ، وهي عاملة في الخطوط الأمامية
انضمت إلى الأطباء الأمريكيين الآسيويين
الآخرين لمكافحة التمييز ،
تحقق من رد فعلها عندما
تفتح الصندوق الذي يحتوي على باربي التي
تبدو مثلها تمامًا ،
يا إلهي ،
لقد فعلوا هذا  وظيفة رائعة
تتحدث عن وظيفة رائعة ما
كنت تفعله في الخطوط الأمامية ، إن
أطقم الدكتور الحقيقية لا تصدق تنضم
إلي الآن للحديث عن كل هذا ،
آه دكتور كروز رأيناك تفتح الصندوق هناك ،
ارشدنا من خلال ما كان
تفكر في ذهنك عندما قمت بإزالة علبة باربي لتكريمك ،
نعم ، مرحبًا باميلا ، شكرًا لك على
استضافتي ، يا إلهي ، كانت تلك اللحظة
سريالية تمامًا لم يكن لدي أي فكرة عما يجب أن أتخيله  ct
ولم أكن أتوقع أن أكون عاطفيًا للغاية
في الوقت الذي كنت أحجم فيه عن البكاء ، لقد
شعرت وكأنها لحظة سريالية كما لو أنها
لم تكن حقيقية بالنسبة لي ،
فقط بالنظر إلى كل التفاصيل التي
لديهم وأنهم  حصلت على حق
بما في
ذلك الشعر ، المعطف الأبيض ،
والخياطة ، حتى اسمي على
المعطف الأبيض ، وهناك أيضًا قناع صغير
هنا ،
كل التفاصيل الصغيرة كانت رائعة ،
كنت في حالة صدمة